last week nintendo thanked the fbi for
arresting bowser and sending him to jail
that's it
that's the video
okay seriously though last week a man
named gary bowser was sentenced to 40
months in a federal prison for uh
selling stuff that let you run pirated
games on your switch
[Music]
alright folks before we get into the
video i just want to remind you all to
please sub to the channel and turn on
notifications because it really does
help okay so back in october 2020 the us
department of justice released a
statement saying that gary bowser along
with a man named maxwell luarn both
members of team executor were arrested
and pending trial team executor were a
hacking group that sold mod chips and
other tools for jailbreaking video game
consoles letting you run pirated games
on them they were actually in operation
for a while according to reporting done
by arch technica's kyle orland who has
sources pinning bowser as kind of a pr
guy for team executor over the years
orlan's report also notes that bowser
has been arrested before for being part
of a counterfeit dvd ring right here in
toronto also he was arrested literally a
few blocks away from me and across the
street from my favorite momo restaurant
so
go to logos and buy a jar of the hot
sauce trust me you'll thank me later
anyway according to orwen's reporting
the video game hacking scene weren't all
super excited by tx selling hacks for
profit which goes against the unwritten
hacker code of ethics but tx was selling
something and it was actually pretty
crazy according to a lawsuit filed by
nintendo in 2020 and obtained by polygon
tx were best known for a device called
the sx pro which was a usb dongle to let
you install a new os onto any switch
released before june 2018 they'll let
you download and run pirated games so to
some degree it's understandable why
nintendo would be so interested in
taking bowser and his compatriots down
they were basically letting people steal
nintendo games but the way the
department of justice puts it is a
little bit more intense than that here's
a quote from acting assistant attorney
general brian c rabbit of the department
of justice's criminal division these
defendants were allegedly leaders of a
notorious international criminal group
that reaped illegal profits for years by
pirating video game technology of us
companies these arrests show the
department will hold accountable hackers
who seek to commandeer and exploit the
intellectual property of american
companies for financial gain no matter
where they may be located side note i
know that everyone is covering the story
because we all think it's funny that the
guy's name is bowser and nintendo's
going after him because you know
bowser's the guy from the nintendo games
but i think the fact that this dude's
name is brian c rabbit is way funnier
anyway basically the justice department
went super hard on these guys because
they see that there is a big difference
between distributing the results of your
hacks for free and selling your hacks to
other people for profit bowser pled
guilty in october then in december he
agreed to pay 10 million dollars to
settle the lawsuit with nintendo of
america which sure seems like a lot of
money that a guy who sold hacks that
only worked on a small percentage of
nintendo switches might not have then
last week bowser got sentenced to 40
months in jail that's three years and
four months in jail all for selling
stuff they'll let you play mario for
free to be fair he only has to pay 4.5
million dollars now but that's still a
lot of
money in their statement the doj said
that bowser's actions as part of tx led
to an estimated 65 million dollars in
losses for video game companies over the
years which seems like an insane number
and a few days later nintendo made a
statement thanking the fbi in a bunch of
us government orbs which in the words of
kotakuzi and walker reads like nintendo
thinks they brought in the pablo escobar
of hacking or something it's kind of
not to mention the fact that the us
government initially wanted bowser to
serve five years of jail time look i
know i'm becoming the is piracy really
that bad person on this channel but like
is piracy really so bad that we're gonna
put a guy in jail for three years and
make him pay 4.5 million dollars
just seems like a lot like making money
off of pirated games is definitely kind
of scummy i don't really support that
but the punishment does feel a little
disproportionate i don't know i'm not a
lawyer i'm just a person who downloaded
a lot of game boy advanced roms from the
pirate bay back in 2007 and then got a
very threatening email from my isp that
made my parents make me promise to never
downloaded pirated games again uh if
you're watching this sad by the way i'm
sorry for lying about that anyway i
guess the point of this whole video is
that we all enjoyed the story because
the pirating guy had a funny name but it
feels a little shitty to laugh now that
his life is basically over because of a
few stupid decisions and archaic
copyright laws
we did have a short shoot once in the
office because we used to film in the in
the space but where people walk between
our office and the uh the office where
like the the like the engineers work
basically like the the the [ __ ] app
people
and we um
developers they're called developers um
and uh we had a three hour short shoot
once because we got interrupted every
five minutes and had to redo the same
lines over and over again